et nous sommes avec l'avocate catherine
casero avocate au barreau de tout membre
du conseil national des barreaux bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin alors
une dixième journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui une mobilisation dans les
cortèges en baisse comment continuer à
faire pression sur le gouvernement avec
cette baisse de la mobilisation alors la
messe de mobilisation sur le plan des
salariés je ne la connais pas ce qui
concerne les avocats en revanche la
mobilisation alors ne faiblit pas elle
voit même s'amplifier le mouvement
puisque tous les barreaux depuis sept
semaines
ce qui est vraiment extraordinaire et
inédits sont en grève et en grève totale
est dur c'est pas de gaîté de coeur que
nous le faisons puisque véritablement
nous sommes en danger
on sait que on va perdre beaucoup dans
cette réforme à la fois sur le plan
financier avec une hausse de nos
cotisations pour les cabinets les plus
faibles une baisse des pensions et puis
surtout une attaque en règle contre
notre indépendance parce qu'il ya aussi
çà et là suppression en tout cas la mise
en danger de la justice de proximité
tout ça fait un ensemble d'étonnant que
nous dénonçons depuis des mois et
des semaines avec ce mouvement de grève
inédit y compris d'ailleurs à paris où
il ya eu une assemblée générale
extraordinaire mais vous manifester
depuis des semaines des mois vous le
dites est ce que vous êtes entendus par
votre ministère de tutelle entendu n'est
pas le cas écoutez peut-être mais
entendu sûrement pas ça fait des mois
que nous expliquons un certain nombre de
choses et ça fait des mois que on nous
répond que ce la réforme qui est
projetée est une réforme qui est
égalitaire pour tous ce qui n'est pas
exact est en tout cas pas chez nous
puisque nous avions mis un système en
place qui étaient telles que l'égalité
et la protection des plus faibles
étaient à l'ordre du jour ce que nous
allons perdre donc non nous ne sommes
pas entendus
donc c'est vrai que la mobilisation des
avocats elle a donné un ton particulier
aux manifestations grèves
interprofessionnelles
est ce qu'il ya un risque de voir votre
profession se retirer si il ya un geste
devait être fait de la part du
gouvernement vers votre profession moi
je pense que le fossé est grand parce
que nous avons une spécificité qui est
telle qu'elle justifierait que quelle
que soit la forme nous puissions
bénéficier d'une autonomie or en l'état
de la situation ce que l'on nous répond
c'est vous rentrerez dans le régime
universel quoi qu'il advienne comme tout
le monde même avec vos spécificités
qu'on reconnaît et y compris d'ailleurs
avec la défense des plus démunis l'accès
au droit enfin tous ces pouvoirs qui
sont quand même qui relève du régalien
est par ailleurs
même un aménagement d'autonomie
dans le régime universel n'est même pas
proposé donc je lire on voit bien que il
n'ya pas une volonté farouche il des
principales revendications le rappelle
un des avocats fait de préserver le
relais cette caisse autonome en fait en
fait c'est préserver un régime autonome
la caisse va de soi avec mais ce qui est
surtout celle régime qui était autonome
est un régime qui est équilibré qui est
solidaires entre nous et qui nous permet
aussi de concourir à hauteur de 100
millions par an à la collectivité
nationale donc en fait le but que veut
affirmer le régime universel c'est ce
que nous nous avons réalisés au fil des
générations
donc c'est ça que nous ne comprenons pas
pourquoi on ne reste pas dans ce schéma
là rien n'empêche de faire un système
pour les salariés peu après probablement
les débats qui ont commencé à
l'assemblée au sein de l'hémicycle
quel regard d'avoir vous portez sur ces
débats qui sont ou bleu et est ce que
vous craignez vous aussi comme le craint
l'opposition que le gouvernement est
bien utilise le 49-3 cet article de la
constitution qui permettra justement un
passage en force du projet de loi
alors je regarde les débats parce que la
commission spéciale a échoué deuxième
temps de l'opération on voit bien qu'il
ya une volonté de confiscation
finalement du débat parlementaire sur
une réforme qui est quand même
dogmatique et d'un autre côté on voit
mal comment on va pouvoir dans le
calendrier qui ne se justifient en rien
il n'y a pas de réseau de cette
précipitation qui sur une réforme qui
est mal ficelé enfin quand dans un texte
on vous renvoie 29 fois des ordonnances
sur des éléments structurants qu'on n'a
pas le financement et qu'on sait pas
comment c'est le régime d'être
équilibrés et qu'on voit que la
conférence de financement est en train
d'échouer vous comprenez quand même
qu'il ya des inquiétudes à avoir et il
aurait fallu prendre du temps parce
qu'elle est mal ficelé elle est mal
rédigée il ya trop d'incertitudes en
traîne une situation anxiogène pour tous
et la finalité puisqu'on pour l'instant
le gouvernement l'exécutif campe sur ses
positions
il n'est pas question de faire marche
arrière du côté des syndicats et des
partenaires professionnels c'est la même
chose donc on va vers quoi une
radicalisation du mouvement
moi je pense qu' il serait temps
peut-être d'avoir un échange qui soit
fructueux parce qu'on est écoutée qu'on
échange là pour l'instant on est dans un
système où nous recevons de
l'information sans réellement échanger
sans être écoutés c'est la méthode déjà
la méthode est critiquable il faut à un
moment donné quand on voit que les
choses coincent à ce point là sur tous
les plans et que tout le monde est
insatisfait d'un système qui n'a pas été
suffisamment étudiée et qui ne tient pas
compte d'un certain nombre de
spécificités
il faut savoir dans un moment
démocratique reconnaître que peut-être
on s'est précipité personne n'a une
science infuse tout le monde peut se
tromper donc dans ces conditions là on
dit ben vous voyez bien que ce n'est pas
la position du gouvernement
mais je sais bien à fait fausse route on
mais on pourrait peut-être dire
remettons simplement travail au
continuant à travailler le texte n'y a
pas d'urgence
en fait dans le temps donc
raisonnablement ça serait de reporter et
puis de voir en l'état de la situation
de 49,3 on comprendrait mal qu'il
s'applique dès lors quand même que en
général c'est quand la majorité flageole
mais la majorité elle était tellement
confortable qu'effectivement il suffit
simplement que les députés votent mais
ça escamote le débat démocratique je
suis pas sûr que ce soit une bonne idée
que ça applaudissent les choses mais bon
ça c'est la volonté gouvernementale ce
n'est pas la note en tout cas nous on
est toujours ouvert à discuter le
problème c'est que pour discuter faut
être deux merci
catherine gaz et ris je rappelle que
vous êtes avocate au barreau de touré
membre du conseil national des barreaux
mercian